je suis prêt
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ils sont tous
morts
tous bords
à sète
m
papa
[Musique]
docile situer et aucune déclaration des
responsables et un éclair nous censés
[Musique]
qui est capable d'exploiter des
émissions radioélectriques de changer la
donne et numérique
et là on est dans l'intelligence
artificielle
maux de tête paranoïa pertes de mémoire
j'ai pas fou je sais ce que je dis vous
allez avoir besoin d'être privé ce que
vous dites
je sais ce que c'est que d'avoir la
guerre qui vous suit jusque dans votre
maison
j'espère que vous pourrez enfin trouver
la paix en sachant qu'au final cette
mission aura été un succès
vous êtes chez vous on n'a pas en
mission c'est très différent non c'est
la même chose
devoir mater imposé
je suis plus moi depuis mon retour
je
non